Now that Git is installed, you'll need to download the asteroids repository.
To do that, you'll need to be somewhere with internet access,
which is why I've left the forest.
Now let's get started and download the repository.
I'm sure you've downloaded files before, but
in this case, what we're doing is a little different.
Because we don't just want to download the actual files,
which would be the files from the most recent comment.
Instead, we want to download the entire history.
Git has a command allowing you to copy an entire repository from one
computer to another.
The command is called git clone because it creates a clone of the repository.
To use it, type git clone followed by a URL to the other repository.
We put the URL for the asteroids repository in the instructors notes, so
go ahead and copy that URL and clone the repository like this.
Now I won't need Internet access anymore for
the rest of the lesson, so I'm going to head back to the forest.
Once the repository is finished cloning, go ahead and cd into it.
Now you should be able to use git log and git diff just like I did earlier.
Go ahead and give it a try.
In order to get the colored diff output like you saw earlier, with the red for
deletions and green for
insertions, run the command git config --global color.ui auto.
If you don't do this, you'll just see black and
white diffs, which will be harder to read.
The git config command just changes your settings in Git and the --global flag
means that it will apply to all of your Git projects and not only this one.
Use git log to find the ID of the commit that reverted the controls.
This commit has the message Revert controls.
Enter the idea of that commit in this box.
Then use git diff to find how many lines were added and
deleted by that commit and enter those numbers here.
Recall that to find the difference between two commits, you use the command git
diff, the ID of the first commit and then the ID of the second commit.